AND THIS IS THE "THE FIVE"
BREAKING NEWS BATTLE OVER
IMPEACHMENT.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS NOW
DEMANDING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY RUDY
GIULIANI HAND OVER DOCUMENTS
ABOUT UKRAINE.
THIS IS THE LATEST MOVE FROM
DEMOCRATS AS THEY MOVE FULL
SPEED AHEAD POTENTIAL
IMPEACHMENT VOTE BY THE END
OF THE YEAR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAMMERING
THE WHISTLEBLOWER AND THE
WHITE HOUSE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHO IT IS.
>> WELL, WE ARE TRYING TO
FIND OUT ABOUT A
WHISTLEBLOWER.
THE CALL WAS PERFECT.
WHEN THE WHISTLEBLOWER
REPORTED IT, HE MADE IT
SOUND TERRIBLE.
AND THEN YOU HAD ADAM SCHIFF
WHO, EVEN WORSE, MADE UP MY
WORDS.
THE REASON IS WHEN HE SAW MY
CALL TO THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, IT WAS SO GOOD THAT
HE COULDN'T QUOTE FROM IT
BECAUSE THERE WAS NOTHING
DONE WRONG.
IT WAS PERFECT.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS SAY A
POTENTIAL HEARING WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER COULD HAPPEN
VERY SOON.
BOTH SIDES SHOWING THEY ARE
DIGGING IN FOR A FIGHT.
>> THIS ALL HEARSAY.
YOU CAN'T GET A PARKING
TICKET CONVICTION BASED ON
HEARSAY.
>> WE COULD NOT IGNORE WHAT
THE PRESIDENT DID.
HE GAVE US NO CHOICE.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT GETTING
JOE BIDEN IN TROUBLE.
THIS IS ABOUT MOVING THE
DONALD TRUMP WAS FRAMED BY
THE DEMOCRATS.
>> THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES
THAT IT IS HIS GOD-GIVEN
RIGHT TO SHAKE DOWN FOREIGN
LEADERS FOR HELPING HIS
REELECTIONS.
>> THE PRESIDENT DID NOTHING
IN THIS PHONE CALL THAT'S
IMPEACHABLE.
>> AND RUDY GIULIANI WAS
JUST SUBPOENAED BY THE
DEMOCRATS ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND SO WE WILL SEE HOW THAT
TURNS OUT.
HE MIGHT TALK ABOUT IT
TONIGHT.
HE WILL BE ON HANNITY 9:00
P.M. EASTERN.
SO YOU CAN CATCH RUDY'S
LATEST THERE.
LET ME FIRST GO TO YOU,
JESSE.
THIS HEARING THAT THE
WHISTLEBLOWER WILL HAVE.
IT WILL BE BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
SO EVEN THOUGH PEOPLE ARE
ANXIOUS TO FIGURE OUT WHO IT
MIGHT BE, THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE AFFORDED UNDER THE
LAW CONTINUE.
>> Jesse: CONGRESS NEVER
LEAKS SO WE ARE NOT GOING TO
HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT THAT
TESTIMONY FOR SURE.
IF THE WHISTLEBLOWER DIDN'T
HEAR THE CALL.
WHO TOLD HIM ABOUT THE STUFF
THAT HAPPENED ON THE CALL
AND WHY DIDN'T THEY BLOW THE
WHISTLE?
WHY DID THEY --
>> Dana: ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT IT SAYS SEVERAL
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: SEVERAL PEOPLE
TOLD THIS ONE GUY.
WHY DID THEY TELL ONE GUY?
SEEMS LIKE A SET-UP TO ME.
WHERE WAS BIDEN THIS
WEEKEND?
WHY WAS BIDEN NOT DOING
EVERY SUNDAY SHOW PULLING
THE FULL QUINCYBERG NOW IN
THE MOMENT OF THE CAMPAIGN
HE WOULD BE OUT THERE
DEFENDING HIS HONOR, WE
BUTTING ALL OF THESE FALSE
ALLEGATIONS ACCORDING TO HIS
CAMPAIGN.
INSTEAD, HE HAD THE MEDIA DO
ALL THE DEFENSE OF HIM.
I GUESS, WHEN YOU ARE
DEMOCRAT YOU CAN LET THE
MEDIA DO THAT.
>> Dana: WHAT'S THE
STRATEGY, DONNA, THEY HAVE
DECIDED TO DOWN PLAY IT.
HE HAS BEEN DOING HIS
CAMPAIGN STUFF BUT NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES
DONE DONE I WOULD AGREE WITH
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S STAFF.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE IS OUT THERE TALKING TO
VOTERS, RAISING MONEY.
TRYING TO MEET THE DEADLINE.
THIS DECISION BY THE HOUSE
TO LAUNCH AN IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY IS ONE OF THEIR
SOLEMN DUTIES.
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
THE FRAMERS GAVE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
I HOPE IT'S CONDUCTED IN A
FAIR MANNER SO THAT WE DON'T
SPEND THE NEXT HOWEVER LONG
TRASHING PEOPLE, DEMONIZING
PEOPLE WHEN IT IS THEIR
SOLEMN DUTY AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONDUCT
THIS IN A FAIR AND ACCURATE
WAY.
>> Dana: WHEN THEY PULL
EVIDENCE LIKE -- I DON'T
KNOW ALL THE DETAILS BUT
WHEN THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS
SUBPOENA SOMEBODY LIKE RUDY
GIULIANI, WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL LAWYER.
HE DOESN'T WORK FOR THE
GOVERNMENT.
BUT HE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT HOW HE HAS TEXT
MESSAGES ON HIS PHONE THAT
SAY THE STATE DEPARTMENT
KNOWS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE LAW
WOULD BE?
DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE
PERSONAL ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE IN THIS CASE OR IS
IT DIFFERENT?
>> Emily: THE
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE
ONLY EXTENDS BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND RUDY GIULIANI.
PART OF WHAT HE WAS SAYING
ON TV AND MULTIPLE OUTLETS
IS THE FACT THAT THIS
PRODUCTION OF DOCUMENTS IS
FROM LIKE MULTIPLE SOURCES,
STATE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVES, ET CETERA.
SO IT'S THOSE DOCUMENTS THAT
CONGRESS IS SUBPOENAING.
NOT CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN HE
AND THE PRESIDENT.
AND IN TERMS OF THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, THAT
DOESN'T APPLY BECAUSE HE
WASN'T WORKING -- THE WHOLE
POINT IS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS A
VEHICLE ACTING ON THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL BEHALF
USING AN INSTRUM OF THE
STATE.
>> Dana: WE ARE ABOUT DAY 10
INTO THIS STORY, GREG.
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING IN
THERE.
>> Greg: NOT WELL.
I HAVE TO SAY I'M SICK OF
THIS STORY.
I'M ABSOLUTELY SICK OF THIS
STORY AND IT'S ONLY BEGUN
AND I REALIZE IT.
WHY AM I SICK OF IT?
BECAUSE I HAVE HEARD IT
BEFORE.
THIS IMPEACHMENT HAS BEEN
SERVED 18 DIFFERENT WAYS,
RIGHT SINCE 2016.
I CAN'T STOMACH IT.
IT'S LIKE THEY KEEP REMIXING
THE SAME HORRIBLE SONG
HOPING THAT IT WILL BE A
HIT.
I CAN TELL IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND I'M GOING TO PUT ON MY
THERAPIST HAT HERE, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO LIKE THE GUY
TO KNOW IT'S B.S.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON THREE
YEARS.
I LIKE THE DODGERS BUT I
KNEW THEY WEREN'T A GOOD
TEAM.
IF YOU WANT TO GET RID OF
THE GUY BECAUSE OF HIS
PERSONALITY, YOU REALIZE
THIS IS GOING TO COME BACK
AND HAUNT YOU.
HALF OF AMERICA IS GOING TO
COME BACK AGAINST YOUR GUY
OR GIRL WHEN THIS HAPPENS.
TRYING TO GET BIDE OFF TV --
NOT BIDEN'S TEAM TRYING TO
GET GIULIANI OFF TELEVISION.
>> Dana: THAT'S A STRANGE
THING.
>> Greg: IT IS A STRANGE
THING ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE ADAM
SCHIFF ON TV.
>> Donna: HE IS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
>> Greg: HE IS STILL A LIAR.
TRIED TO GET NAKED PICTURES
OF TRUMP.
>> Dana: WE ACTUALLY,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A CALL FOR
THAT VERY CALL YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> Greg: I HAD NO IDEA.
>> WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THAT
CALL RECORD IS A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES USE THE
FULL WEIGHT OF HIS OFFICE TO
MANUFACTURE DIRT ON HIS
OPPONENT.
>> SO HAVE YOU RECORDINGS OF
BOTH WHERE THEY ARE
DISCUSSING THE COMPROMISING
MATERIAL ON MR. TRUMP?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY, WE WOULD
WELCOME A CHANCE TO GET
COPIES OF THOSE RECORDINGS.
>> Dana: THAT WAS DURING A
PRANK CALL.
DON'T EVER ANSWER A PRANK
CALL.
>> Jesse: HE DIDN'T KNOW IT
WAS A PRANK CALL.
HE THOUGHT IT WAS LEGIT.
DEMOCRATS CAN ASK FOREIGNERS
TO INVESTIGATE TRUMP BUT
TRUMP CAN'T ASK FOREIGNERS
TO INVESTIGATE DEMOCRATS.
GOT IT?
THIS IS COMING OUT OF BIDEN
CAMPAIGN.
THEY KEEP SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT?
EVERYBODY IN EUROPE WANTED
THIS ONE PROSECUTOR FIRED.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, I
WONDER WHY THAT IS?
AND I WENT TO START LOOKING?
WHO WAS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF BURR
DIRECTORS OF.BURR
BURISMA GUESS
WHAT I FOUND RENAISSANCE
COUNCIL THE RUSSIAN
INVESTMENT BANK THAT PAID
BILL CLINTON A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS TO SPEAK IN
MOSCOW.
HE IS A DIRECTOR.
THEN WE HAVE COFFEER BLACK,
CIA FORMER PRESIDENT OF
POLAND AND DEVIN ARCHER WHO
IS JOHN KERRY'S FORMER
FOREIGN POLICY ADVISOR.
VERY WELL-CONNECTED.
VERY WEALTHY GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS.
AND THEY WANTED TO GET THE
WORD OUT TO THEIR FRIENDS
THAT THIS GUY WAS A CORRUPT
INVESTIGATOR AND HE NEEDED
TO BE FIRED.
BUT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE FOUND SOME DOCUMENTS THAT
PROVE THAT WAS A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
BURISMA HIRED I BELIEVE IT
WAS A BLUE STAR STRATEGIES,
A D.C. CONSULTING FIRM TO
PUT OUT THE FAKE NEWS ABOUT
THE PROSECUTOR THAT
EVERYBODY BOUGHT AND THEN
THE GUY GETS FIRED AND THE
BLUE STAR STRATEGY GROUP
CAME BACK TO UKRAINE AND
APOLOGIZED FOR PUTTING OUT
ALL THIS FAKE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR PROSECUTOR.
AND UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR WHO
WAS FIRED TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH THAT HE WAS FIRED
BECAUSE HE WOULDN'T DROP
THIS INVESTIGATION INTO THE
FIRM THAT JOE BIDEN'S SON
WAS A MEMBER OF.
AND JOE BIDEN, THE SON, WERE
NEVER INVESTIGATED.
THE BIDEN APPOINTED
PROSECUTOR, WHO CAME IN
AFTER THE OTHER GUY WAS
FIRED, NEVER OPENED UP AN
INVESTIGATION INTO JOE BIDEN
OR HIS SON.
SO, HE NEVER INVESTIGATED
HIM.
AND HE NEVER CLEARED HIM AND
I WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT
OF FAKE NEWS OUT THERE ABOUT
THIS STORY.
>> Greg: I WANT TO COMPLETE
A THOUGHT, WHY DID -- NANCY
PELOSI SAID WHY THIS PHONE
CALL WAS IMPORTANT.
IT WAS BECAUSE IT WAS A
SIMPLER, CLEARER WAY TO
IMPEACH TRUMP SO THAT THE
PUBLIC WOULD UNDERSTAND IT.
RIGHT?
THIS WAS AN EASIER WAY FOR
THEM TO UNDERSTAND IT.
THIS HAS ALL BEEN LIKE A
CINDERELLA SLIPPER.
THEY HAVE BEEN SEARCHING FOR
THAT ONE SHOE THAT'S GOING
TO FIT.
THEY WENT THROUGH A
WAREHOUSE OF SHOES BEFORE
THEY GOT TO THIS ONE.
IF THEY DON'T FIND THIS ONE
THEY WILL FIND ANOTHER.
WE KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
>> Dana: DONNA, DO YOU HAVE
LAST WORD HERE.
>> Donna: THERE IS SO MUCH
THAT I CAN DEBUNK WE HAVE
JUST AN HOUR.
ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE
ENJOYED READING ABOUT ALL OF
THIS AND CHANGE OF NARRATIVE
I HEAR NOT JUST FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AND ALLIES OF
THE WHITE HOUSE BUT ALSO A
CHANGE IN INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE GETTING OUT OF
UKRAINE.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED AN
INQUIRY, SO THAT WE CAN
LEARN THE FACTS, EXPOSE THE
TRUTH.
AND THE MORE WE GET INTO
THIS HYPER BOWL AND TRY TO
DEFEND OUR SIDES AND NOT
LOOKING AT THE TRUTH, THE
FARTHER AWAY WE ARE GOING TO
GET FROM RESOLVING THIS
MATTER.
>> Emily: QUICK FINAL POINT
ON STRATEGY.
JUST TO RESPOND WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING ABOUT THE GLASS
SLIPPER.
THE HARDEST CASES TO PROOF
IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
PERCEPTION ARE THE ONES
WHERE YOU KEEP AMENDING THE
COMPLAINT OR CHARGING
DOCUMENT.
THE FACT THIS HAS BEEN A
SLOW LEAK, A FESTERING WOUND
FOR YEARS WITHOUT THIS
PROVERBIAL SMOKING GUN MEANS
THAT THE COURT -- OR THE
PUBLIC IS TOTALLY FATIGUED.
WE ARE EXHAUSTED.
THERE IS NOTHING.
THERE IS NO AH-HA.
IT'S NOT A TIGHT CASE.
>> Dana: WE WILL SEE.
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Donna: WOULD BE A MATTER
OF CONSIDERATION.